peu madame
question pour le regarder juste une
petite regarder on est là tiens journée
bousquet ses touches mais y'a rien on va
vous poser une petite question va vous
demander seulement pour le rtf si jean
pierre marielle vous fait rire oui vous
savez qui c'est une petite question pour
le rtf on peut vous demander une petite
chose pour l'acheter vous avez bien noir
j'aime beaucoup l'ont été parce que jean
pierre marielle vous fait rire oui celle
qui sait écouter nos cieux je n'entends
rien tant précisément mais enfin le rdr
qui me plaît beaucoup de choses me font
rire beaucoup choses aussi sont
normalement triste comme il le faut
alors si ceux ci sont firme ariel si je
ne le connais pas je m'excuse auprès de
lui
les yeux et les oreilles pour l'obrc
madame malgré les événements actuels
oui non sans fierté est ce que est ce
que jean pierre marielle vous fait rire
connais pas pièce de mort jean pierre
marielle connaissait pas non seulement
quelques choses m'ont fait part d'un
acteur
vous connaissez jean pierre marielle
c'est vous est ce que jean pierre
marielle vous fait rire oui beaucoup
jacques n'est pas venue a répondu je
connais c'est pas non vous l'avez jamais
vu non et c'est parfait il vous fait
rire oui chers téléspectateurs
bonsoir je vous rappelle brièvement le
principe de notre émission notre invité
d'aujourd'hui jean pierre marielle a
convoqué un intervieweur choisi parmi
les journalistes les plus plats et
quelques amis qui n'ont pu résister au
plaisir de venir
philippe de broca daniel boulanger jean
rochefort guy bedos sans sophie daumier
et rémo forlani
[Musique]
cher jean pierre magne je voudrais vous
nous évoquer votre enfance légendaire à
ces photos charmante si vos charmantes
était président en juillet une maison
qui appartenait à mes petits camarades
d'enfance
ce qui je passais mes vacances c'était à
combret dans la beauce une vieille
maison exquis
mais il y avait une bonne il s'occupait
de nous une bonne françoise faisait des
asperges avait un peu connes c'est
marrant les romans et a toujours des
bonnes tandis que dans la vie enfin ça
c'est un portrait que l'on m'a fait à
hollywood je t'ai parti pour l'amérique
ça n'a pas très bien marché à la métro
goldwyn mayer on m'a dit on vous écrira
pas de travestis dans nos films on a
préféré charles et en paix on a fait
quelque chose que je suis rentré en
france pendant un petit moment ça n'a
pas très bien marché mais enfin j'ai
persévéré
très vite j'ai commencé à jouer dans des
petits théâtres niro d'enfants tout ça
c'était du temps de ma jeunesse à jamais
disparu maintenant voilà tel que je suis
dans les théâtres et sur les écrans
parisiens avec ou sans moustache
alors je vois là je vous montrer mon
profil gauche celui qu'on utilise le
plus souvent au cinéma parce que le
meilleur le droit de face mais puis-je
utilisent généralement dans mes films
3,4 expression mais meyers
voilà je fais ça a également étonné
aussi beaucoup et puis
bah c'est à peu près tout j'arrive à
gagner ma vie avec ces quelques petites
choses que je sais faire et la calvitie
la part dont on ne montre pas sa petite
calvitie aux téléspectateurs l'accord au
d'où vient le comique de marielle à moi
je crois que ça vient précisément de
ceux de ça c'est une raison
à la base physique d'une façon de bouger
avoir un trop grand corps des trop
grandes jambes d'être au grand bras dont
il joue admirablement et les halons gens
peuvent ils les îles ceux des cadres des
choses je dire qu'ici vous demande du
sel c'est comme s'il allait chanter le
tennis oui c'est exact c'est ce c7 sniil
a pas un front et 3 bizarrement mais il
fait il joue il il se déroule toujours
pour pour bourbon pour baisser son front
pour pour rapetisser souvent c'est ça
c'est je crois ce décalage entre cette
voix cette voix de tragédien ce physique
de 2,2 des reculs parce qu'il est
admirablement bâti avec cette tête
d'oiseau perchée sur de grandes épaules
c'est physique au départ youth un tout
petit peu oui
ah c'est beau surtout qu'elle accentue
c'est la voix jeudi rassemble deux
choses décalées je crois décalé avec
avec au moins un coup tu es tu sais
écouter solitaire au t2 l'oeil un point
qui est du grand échassier
c'est une phrase aussi vous dire
il reçoit elle ressemble c'était une
femme marianne n'a rien de la femme au
semblait-elle ces grands oiseaux que
l'on appelle des demoiselles de numidie
c'est un peu ça mais la même dans l'oeil
ils sont sur une patte on sait pas s'ils
sont tout à fait d'un plan tout à fait
hommes vont-ils déplier l'autre je suis
rentrée au conservatoire avec les trois
de saint cyr et d'ailleurs c'est très
curieux parce que j'ai joué beaucoup de
rôles de militaires servant et je suis
sorti du conservatoire dans les trois
dossiers du bas égal ferrer et j'ai
uniquement travailler des scènes ou
âgées travailler les trois font la paire
j'ai travaillé et vous allez me demander
pourquoi c'est très simple parce que
nous étions trois aux amis et nous
avions envie de travailler toujours
ensemble alors nous choisissions
toujours des scènes où il ya les trois
personnages y avait jean paul belmondo
il y avait jean rochefort et je ne sais
pas du tout ce qu'il est devenu
justement jeu si vous permettez je
voudrais
chien voilà je voudrais dire situés en
france ou à l'étranger
cher jean rochefort j'aimerais bien te
revoir ça me ferait plaisir
j'ai gardé un souvenir ému de nos années
de jeunesse et j'aimerais bien savoir ce
que tu es devenu voilà alors écrit moi
suite de cette émission si tu as la
chance de l'avoir et je serai ravi de te
retrouver
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle pour vous
jean pierre marielle oui jean rochefort
et dans le studio 4 o il vous attend
[Musique]
vous êtes retrouvé grâce à la télévision
own faire plus plaisir je dis merci
albert tf
[Musique]
oh la la
assieds toi alors tu es venu oui je suis
arrivé ça fait si longtemps tu écrivais
c'était quoi c'était en 50 51 nous oui
on était au conservatoire tu m'avais
invité leurs tableaux en bretagne
et oui ça peut saint-guirec près de
saint malo de montendre ces lois qui
prévoient une place et louis jean pierre
marielle à la réputation de commander
dans la roue de métier de tirer la
couverture à lui et ayant défié de se
placer au premier rang ce que j'aimerais
oui quand ça lui est possible
effectivement mais avec moi ça fait n'a
jamais eu l'occasion de pouvoir le faire
parce que je suis toujours sur le
qui-vive vous comprenez bien
effectivement il a cette réputation
il a dû pendant quelques années une
perruque tournante d'ailleurs qu'il
employait en toutes circonstances
mais ça ne faisait pas rire les gens
parce que j'arrivais à me mettre devant
lui à ce moment là ou alors il a essayé
jets d'eau au milieu de la perruque ça
va marcher non plus je suis désolé de
dire cela mais enfin il faut dire les
choses comme elles sont vous étés dans
la prochaine fois je vous le chanterai
la prochaine fois je me suis entré il a
essayé décaler la pièce non mais enfin
je le dis je dis je crois vous été le
plus loin dans notre là dedans dans le
cabotinage véhicule et le ridicule
ridicule c'est dans le diable par la
queue à mon avis oui je n'ai pas de
souvenir
j'avais moi même j'ai interprété le rôle
du tu compte de coûts steam que c'était
un personnage absolument magnifique que
j'ai pensé je crois avec beaucoup de
talent et sans ce professionnel ce sens
professionnel qui me caractérise jean
ping oui alors je me souviens je me
souviens très bien on compte nous avons
été contactés par philippe de broca pour
jouer ça il avait été question de
marielle à un moment mais producteurs ne
voulait pas de lui y est je crois que là
j'ai fait un geste
voilà enfin oui bah disons le si je
n'avais pas insisté tu ne faisais pas ce
film alors effectivement on l'a pris un
petit peu encore la face et un rôle
beaucoup plus important au départ un
scénario heureusement on peut couper et
c'était nécessaire
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la critique
qui disait que jean pierre marie en
faisait beaucoup trop et jean rochefort
pas assez alors études
oui c'est une critique mal an c'est
vraiment notre époque qui mise en
accusation jeudi immédiatement gens bien
ariel en fait trop évidemment merci le
genre mais non mais tu m'as demandé de
venir je suis venu bon bah merci crampel
me revient derrière marionnettes un
moine c'est un deal il est fait pour
donner des coups de couteau je suis
persuadé il n'aura vraiment que il doit
porter quelques silice que juste comme
ça toujours en dessous c'était il doit
aimer et c'est pour lui faire plaisir
qu'on a pensé à lui donner un rôle qui
lui finalement n'aimait pas au départ
vous demander ce qu était un petit peu
maso qu'il a
et quand il veut absolument tout réussir
c'est ça marchait tout seul mais je
crois encore une fois que c'est
véritablement un mois et brûlant
intérieur est toujours dangereux de
vouloir donner des coups de couteau ça
je n'en démords pas en sortant du
conservatoire comme beaucoup de
camarades j'ai joué dans les petits
théâtres de la rive gauche
j'ai joué au théâtre et bill au théâtre
de la huchette bon vieux colombier au
studio des champs elysées des pièce de
ionesco brecht michel de ghelderode
après je suis rentré dans la compagnie
grenier hussenot
quel est votre envie de premier rôle un
patron de bar oui vous pouvez ou alors
je vais peut-être aller en attendant
s'est passé bien jusqu'ici
si si je crois oui attention
voilà alors oui ça va aller merci alors
là francis girod christian le lieu ils
sont de l'autre côté de la caméra en ce
moment on tourne et de la part de qui au
sujet de la pellicule mais de la
pellicule en plus oui mais bon ne
peuvent avoir que deux mille cinq cents
mètres de pellicule
bah pourquoi ils trouvent que 2500
mètres c'est énorme pour moi c'est
comment dois je prendre bien ou mal
bâle alors je le prends très très mal
enfin on va on va se débrouiller quand
on peut oui bon on va tourner sans
pellicule bonne leçon passera puis on
passera à mickey pierre jean pierre
marielle vous aviez souhaité avoir vu
d'autres avec nous cet après midi
d'aujourd'hui et je crois qu'il est il a
beaucoup insisté il est neuf c'est mon
avenir graves abus lors d'un tournage du
film ensemble c'est toi
bah c'est gentil je suis content de te
voir ça fait ça fait une paye dragées au
poivre c'était hier c'est plutôt parce
que oui ça va j'ai vu les trucs de toi
ça ça a l'air de marcher bienne oui si
tu t'en sors et je suis content c'est
difficile à la salle fantaisie tous
vous savez pas vous mais moi j'ai pas
fais vraiment une
non c'est d'ailleurs des meilleurs
comédiens que tu as joué cette année par
oui je ne te dire une enfin je bouge
plus j'achète plus branché sur sur le
large la rigolade bus ce qui est très
étonnant c'est la technique que tu veux
ouais je tourne un portage pourront pas
faire ce que tu fait voyager je pourrais
pas jeter 10 dans la pièce le forlani
oui tu pourrais pas si j'étais baba
j'étais baba vraiment temps c'est
difficile c'est difficile c'est
difficile de bien jouer la comédie
nos remarques il suffit de te remettre
un peu le pied à l'étrier pts non et
n'oubliez pas petit je sais que j'y
arriverai pas j'y arriverai pas faire ça
jamais mon peuple écoute du ca me fait
plaisir tout ce que tu me dis ah non je
crois non non non je veux dire c'était
sincère enfin je dis gentiment face à
face et c'est sûr qu'on fait sur moi
j'ai créé des détritus blanc m'a demandé
au départ de justement d'être enfin
d'être gentil avec toi mais enfin je
vais enfin sur me force pas tellement
quoi je viens je les fais sincèrement
quand un homme enterre hommage et quand
on ne paye pas pour être gentil avec moi
c'est moi qui tu quittes fait annoncer
je vais tâcher bras c'est que tu veux
c'est pas la télévisi c'est moi je te
plains jamais prononcé gentil mais enfin
je ne veux pas de ça entre nous écoute
pas on va s'y voit mélo et il ya ba non
parce que on peut pas fumer deux amants
on peut pas fumer et deux parce qu'après
ça fait un peu de trucs on veux me
tourner mes boîtes ou non mais je veux
pas tu aimais beaucoup et c'est bon de
voir ça ça va pas être bon pour moi
cette émission finalement parce que
finalement je publie enfin des gens qui
m'ont pas de pub a été noté dans moi je
vois c'est déjà prendre quelle est la
vôtre avis le premier rôle vraiment
déterminant pour vous c'est une pièce de
jean bernard lui qui s'appelait
hibernatus commenté georges vitaly au
théâtre de l'athénée
et ça ça a été très important parce que
le
c'est la première fois que la critique
m'a repéré un petit peu repérer et quand
vous êtes elle remarqué dans la première
fois alors remarqué et ben vraiment
remarqué bahia pro tellement longtemps
enfin il ya trois quatre ans mais enfin
j'ai toujours travaillé régulièrement
enfants bat vraiment remarqué trois ans
théâtre antoine quand nous avons joué
des pièces avec delphine seyrig jean
rochefort et claude régy piéplu garcin
et puis plus proche de nous il ya 25
jours
oh
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des gens qui
on reproche une certaine vulgarité
langage de fardani bon alors là j'en
pense rien du tout parce que je trouve
qu'il ya aucune vulgarité dans le
langage de forlan est rien la fia a
d'abord qu'ils disent est là dans son
livre l'homme et l'enfant et disait de
la vulgarité des gentils trouve tout
vulgaire je lui à l'acteur communiqué
side est reconnu comme on part communale
acteur comique
je ne crois pas du tout que marielle ce
contre un bond au type encore une fois
au fond vous l'imaginez absolument en
moine alors dire une tiendrait très bien
le rôle du curé d'uruffe par exemple
confesseur professeur troubles
c'est le diable quelqu'un me fait
souvent rire
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui vous fait
rire oui il ya quelqu'un qui me fait
rire c'est serge d'avril mais moi j'aime
les dames et voici votre courrier du
coeur et pour la belle et gentille
petite isabelle je chanterai une chanson
d'amour une chanson grise une chanson de
griserie dany leclerc rue je suis sakho
les rues se pique des colères se pique
des colères plus le je suis en colère
revenus oui ils y ont largement porte
pour gagner parce qu'il faut que je
fasse en sorte que ça fasse du bruit et
je prends mes seins sur ma femme qui
crie sur son père qui m'ennuie sur ma
belle-mère qui gueule que et surtout
betty non admis sur les enfants c'est
très mauvais c'est nul
moi je n'ai pas ri il mène une souris
une procédure comment pourrais-je dire
mauvaise mère c'est de mal
il a plu 10 heures qui viennent par
avion
allez petite soeur kiplagat qui ait
souillé par chez lui on cherche
authentique goût pour l'audiovisuel pour
la forme la couleur au 16 mai lie à rien
et ça c'est nul
j'assure qu'à marseille c'est ce qu'ils
étaient des génies qu est ce qui ne
l'est pas fait n'importe quoi suis-je en
infligeant infligeant affichant une
question je voudrais bien vous poser est
ce que vous pensez que dans notre
société de consommation
les acteurs ou encore un rôle à jouer
enfin je veux dire est ce que ce qu'ils
ont encore une responsabilité sociale
oui
non
[Rires]
[Musique]